[Music]
uh it has been a fun day today where is
that ah there it is okay this is
something else
[Music]
remember Office Space
when they fix the glitch yeah of course
okay well guess what
they fixed the glitch Elon Musk making
sorry immersed it's Michael Strahan
again I apologize
how come how come Birdman be mean to me
well that's a man why is a rocket man
being so mean to people on Twitter we're
gonna look into that
wow
it's a pumpkin
all right my eyes are so far apart they
had to recalibrate the the teletron for
me hey George can I have a few questions
can he use the Rockets to fuel Twitter
[Music]
I don't know how that would work but um
Michael I don't I don't think you do
that Michael
I'm here with rich man that run Twitter
pylon pylon how you do how you do
farming firing people musk making major
moves after his takeover at Twitter tell
an employee layoffs will begin later
this morning Janae Norman is at the New
York Stock Exchange with the latest good
morning Janae
she's more of like outside the New York
Stock Exchange yeah right she said I'm
in the [ __ ] trenches right she's at
the Capitol Burger across the street
from the [ __ ] clock exchange thank
you Michael they wouldn't allow me in
the building today they already had the
uh maximum required number of blacks
which is shockingly three yeah overnight
some employees already getting word that
they've been laid off by Twitter amid
more turmoil out that's [ __ ] stock
footage is what the [ __ ] that is she's
in front of a green screen no no I don't
think so in his first company wait now
you're me now you're [ __ ] me up is
she dude
there is a glow hold on now yeah there
is you see it right like the yeah
sometimes it happens to us that kind of
look around the hair look around the
hair okay I'm gonna press play while she
moves hold on any wide email on Thursday
Elon Musk riding team hold on a second
no no no no no no no no no no no no I'm
an artist for this [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
green no no but they said hold on one
minute that the New York Stock exchange
with the latest good morning Janae
Michael good morning overnight some
employees already getting word that
they've been laid off by Twitter amid
more turmoil at the company I don't know
man first company-wide email on Thursday
Elon Musk riding team in an effort to
place Twitter on a healthy path we will
go through the difficult process of
reducing our Global Workforce on Friday
firing them on a Friday
we just fixed the glitch recognize that
this will impact a number of individuals
who have made valuable contributions to
Twitter but this action is unfortunately
necessary to ensure the company's
success moving forward the email saying
employees will be notified of their job
status by 9 A.M Pacific time today
although some were notified at midnight
and were immediately locked out of their
accounts in the meantime those are the
people that had access to the back end
stuff yeah the back end access yeah
which makes sense I mean this isn't even
like being vindictive if you were doing
this at any company you would do that
the people of course you have to Google
would do the same closed in badge access
suspended and the move comes just a week
after musk took control of the company
and immediately fired top Executives
including the CEO and CFO in the wake of
muft's new leadership The Wall Street
Journal reporting a growing list of
companies now pausing advertisements on
the platform and overnight workers
filing a class-action lawsuit over the
massive now let's get into that Virgie
explain what happened with that class
action lawsuit and the lawyers trying to
make money off of them being fired well
see what's funny about that is that he
didn't fire anybody on today he didn't
he didn't fire anybody he sent him an
email letting them know that they were
now on a non-working status with the
company that their employment was still
in state for the next 90 days which is
illegal which is the legal requirement
in California so they're furloughed
environment California yeah they're
[ __ ] so they are fired they will be
they're gonna get paid for three months
of not working by the way they will they
will three months vacation they should
be [ __ ] thanking him
um so that lawsuit's not going to do
anything because he had every right to
do it as long as he followed law which
he did he could as long as he's paying
you doesn't mean he doesn't have to give
you access to the building or even
access to the computer you just need to
give you a paycheck and you're getting
one so congratulations three month
vacation I don't know go to The French
Laundry I heard it's nice this time of
year
to all the ambulance chasing lawyers on
Twitter are all going oh don't sign
anything that was sent from Twitter they
weren't giving anything to son yet by
the way good news by the way here's the
thing good news though a lot of the
people that were fired already know how
to code so they're a step ahead there
you go you know we won't even say it
this time even though technically we're
probably allowed to now it would
actually be funny just that despite move
Elon hires like a bunch of actual coal
miners that turn the learner code he
teaches them how to code and replaces
their jobs with them I would personally
teach them would be so funny
playoffs saying that the company is
doing hey Elon hear me out
hear me out here do me a favor
you made the first PayPal can you make
another one
because they just secretly reinstated
that 2500 for misinformation remember
they took it off they just put it back
in quietly I see one of the lawyers that
[ __ ] hack yeah
same thing Virgie said don't sign
anything yeah
Wing show without enough note here's the
thing they don't need to sign anything
notice in violation of federal and
California law Michael he didn't get but
here's the thing he gave him 90 days so
he didn't do that see that's the thing
your report your reporting is faulty a
lot going on there Janae a lot going on
there Janine wow that's crazy you know
but you know I don't understand how
computers work but
I certainly hope that these workers can
get back inside the computer
so let's continue their Noble work thank
you that was a great report
can you go inside the computer yeah okay
all right so maybe a little inside
baseball we were looking for an Elon
story before Marsh came on WE Verge was
like well we got to do the straight hand
one obviously
hey why come when you go in the computer
to fix it sometimes you get loaded into
the game and you have to fight the user
with Bob the guardian and then there's a
kid named Enzo oh he was watching Tron
again huh there is a new job report by
the way Miami gilf uh in the uh local
chat
that's what I call it okay um it's she's
uh she's the exclusive Velvet Rope
locals chat she did point out it's only
60 day notice he's actually being
generous he's giving you an extra month
oh my God that's a covered his ass he
did it to cover his ass but it was very
smart yeah fine give him an extra month
but I'm not gonna pay him for another 10
years get him the [ __ ] out joking aside
she actually would know so that actually
you're right you get 30 extra days
he's doing the 90 days because there's
employees in the UK and their laws 90
days
poured out this one imagine trying to
own a business in Europe you know the
best part is in Florida it's like you're
fired you wouldn't have to give you a
reason yeah in Florida to get out it's a
right to work state so it's like not bye
I'll just heat you up and then throw you
out if I'm if I'm Elon
um first off nice [ __ ] Amber Heard
that's pretty cool but also if I'm Elon
I move the company immediately out of
California I don't care to [ __ ] Idaho
but some place it's not there take that
company out of there that way they can't
even [ __ ] with you that I mean that's
what I would do right and me and they're
oh they're complaining okay so here's
the thing next thing sorry because we
have a lot there's a lot on this story
um some of the employees found uh were
these are some of the employees that
have been fired we have some salt do you
want to mine a little bit of salt oh I
love me some salt mining okay this is
Akasha right right not gonna work here
anymore I was fired from Twitter this
morning I was responsible for reporting
tweets for Content abuse this dude has
turned into a meme if you go in search I
was fired from Twitter this morning
there are just droves of people going I
was fired from Twitter this morning I
was responsible for getting Davis coffee
it's very funny the next one this is uh
Simon Balmain
um looks like I'm unemployed y'all just
got remotely logged out of my work
laptop and removed from Slack
uh one team forever loved you all so
much so sad it had to end this way
[Music]
Lindsay Candor it's insane because I
knew it was coming but I'm absolutely
ripped in half I'm embarrassed for
posting this but it hurts because this
company was so damn special
love where you work
oh she's gonna miss all the free sushi
and the wine bar on the roof just
these people
I'm so happy and the power tripping oh
that's a good point then are you really
gonna miss the power tripping you have
no more you have no more power and the
other one there's other ones that are
complaining merch you're gonna love this
they're complaining because he's going
to make the ones that are staying he's
gonna make them go back into the office
to work and not work remote anymore
there
they're gonna melt down no they are
melting now that is what's actively
happening is they're melting down right
now it's gonna get worse when I have to
go back into work though yeah I posted a
couple of those meme Tweets in the and
the locals chat I think I think it might
have been Babylon B but one of them was
like oh
Twitter employees are pissed because
Elon Musk keeps walking around and doing
a bad Borat impression
around the office hey my wife
I want to see him go to the office like
Ari and uh [ __ ] what do you call it
Entourage yeah with the paintball gun
just blasting there just walking through
like oh yeah I remember that yeah yeah
who's your number one client uh the
Aaron Sorkin blah blah blah blah blah
it's just like walking through the face
just blasting everybody